Elon Musk was speaking at a New York
Times event and he was asked about
advertisers and the boycott and he said
go f yourselves and we're going to play
that video for you he said anybody who
wants to try blackmailing me with money
go after yourselves in a powerful
statement he goes on to talk about his
motivations and he makes really great
points they are these companies that
pretend to do good while doing evil just
so they can earn those ESG scores
whereas he sees what he's working on is
genuinely doing good but being attacked
relentlessly I agree we got more news
too this morning Rumble announced a
lawsuit against a group of activists
that Target conservative Media or just
in general politics and uh media
platforms they don't like and try to get
their ads pulled Chris P pavlovski the
CEO said the Cavalry is here announcing
this lawsuit and well the rumor is
there's going to be many many more
lawsuits and uh uh before the show I saw
very very interesting story UFOs and you
know what that means Hunter Biden's in
the news again